a car can be as important a character in
a movie as any of the actors the right
vehicle in the right location makes a
statement but getting it there can be
tough expensive or even impossible enter
the Blackbird a shape-shifting car that
can mimic other vehicles real vintage
priceless or even imagined there's great
seeing this thing driving in but none of
this is real this is all movie magic
Allister you're from the mill the yaks
company that make this magic you can let
me have a little go so just kind of look
fantastic right now we can you can see
the reflections of the buildings around
us in it yes and I can turn those off
then we can turn off the color and now
we just left for the show let's turn
that off then we've got this wireframe
we get rid of that this is the blanket
this is your baby this is the machine
that makes these effects possible talk
us through it how does it work so this
is a modular vehicle we can extend the
length by four feet and the width by 10
inches the only part that needs to be
real is the wheels and any type from any
manufacturer can be bolted on pretty
much everything else though is made in a
computer and draped over the Blackbird
afterwards this is a camera array you
have a stabilization hit here this is
the smallest stabilization head in the
world it's kind of like a Steadicam on
its left side the four cameras here grab
an outwards facing view their images can
be stitched together for a 360 degree
look at the world they're crucial to the
realistic effect they're used to make
the reflections we saw of buildings
people and other cars we take the image
we get from here and we turn that into a
360 degree go black triangles on the
frame are used to lock that dome into
exactly the right position even when the
cars moving then the color the trim and
any other details can be manipulated in
the computer giving the filmmakers total
control and blurring the boundary
between our world and the virtual one
just that little bit more
get on with his business so Robert thank
you very much your patients like you
well let you can't crack on Cheers
[Music]
you